[Music]
ladies and gentlemen hello thank you for
sticking with us it is now 10 12 p.m in
the evening west coast time
i hope you guys are ready
for the team coco eating contest yeah so
here's how it's gonna go we are going to
it's a point system as you see right
here on this uh handy dandy
professionally written up board uh we
have three competitors names uh each
competitor uh the person with the most
points at the end of the eating contest
will win so what's going to happen is
we're going to bring out a food that you
guys will get to choose and uh the
person we're going to say go the person
to finish their food the fastest
according to the judge this guy right
here in the lumberjack shirt will get a
point that's right if you are unable to
finish if you were unable to finish at
all
you will get minus one point
tuna
or a cheesecake
one two three go
right off the bat todd's got the hands
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god dude
i think he was speaking also how does he
do that that's crazy
donuts
or hamburgers donuts or hamburgers
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
he called it like babe rude wow
ten nuggets on each plate one point for
every plate finished and how many plates
do we have anybody know
let's get a plate for each one of these
guys you guys ready episodic challenge
let's do it apartment
now we're just putting plugs okay you
know what uh just stop eating
nuggets down
just
uh guys thank you so much for joining us
uh todd let's get here for todd a big
winner tonight
crush the competition
and uh thank you thank you guys for
joining us we have a whole slate of
programming going on later tonight
please follow us uh teamcoco.com
facebook.comcoco youtube.com
teamcoco we love you all thank you for
your comments see you guys soon peace